what's up guys I'm been mines
correspondent for the e network and good
morning america but tonight I'm the host
for the 6th annual Holly shorts festival
it's my second year doing this so talk
about it yeah I guess I didn't mess up
last year too badly for having me
and what's your connection to
independent film I'm first and foremost
I'm a fan even before my days working in
the business I was always seeking out
independent films and short films
especially you know we don't get too
many platforms for short film sometimes
it's tough to seek out but Holly shorts
is a great job putting together a
wonderful lineup but it is something
like 200 films and compositions and I'm
just a fan of great movies regardless of
different big studio or made out of
shoestring budget it doesn't matter it's
just about good work on screen asking
these festivals are they coming from
some body
this is your second year what stands out
about some of the winners what do you
think the key ingredients all I think
I've been passion you know sometimes
when you have a limited budget or
resources to play with the thing that
you can really drive your project
through is having passion from behind
the camera and the crew and directed to
the actors on screen it's all labor of
love so I feel like the films that
really kind of rise to the top you can
feel that energy on stream